I just don't want to admit or even
accept the idea that it's just whatever
we had as a family is gone
they don't have a choice
this is a big change the family as we
know it no longer exists when she was
talking it was like released like she
had released the relationship I could
see it I could fill it on early oh yeah
I I recognize it
you've been there yeah
it's just so familiar
and I've seen Cody give up on me and him
I didn't give up on Mary
it just turned out the relationship was
essentially unstable I just didn't feel
like it was tenable it's not a
functional relationship and we can get
along but we can't be together
people have asked me people are always
asking me
like why do you stay you don't have a
relationship with them
and I
think on it and I pray on it and I
meditate on it and I always come to a
peace with it
I'm just grateful that you're sticking
it out
she belongs with us
hang on with me okay
I am
we have to rebuild
we have to rebuild
right
yeah I know we do
just hang on with me okay
I really wanted to live plural marriage
and give that big picture of the whole
family to my kids
Ari is five years old they are not even
gonna get to experience it
I I want that for my kids but I I also
foreign
[Music]
I had other choices
this is what I wanted
I just
to watch as they destroy what I wanted
I just can't let it go
[Music]